[Music]
okay ladies you're making some serious
waves and breaking all the royalty rules
come on your Disney princesses after all
doesn't that mean you're supposed to be
polished and perfect we're just kidding
you're trailblazers and rule breakers
and we are loving it
that's why we keep coming back to watch
your adventures we can't wait to see
what roles you'll break next you
fabulous ladies are some of the biggest
rebels of all time if you're like that
you love watching Disney Princesses turn
into total royal rebels we've lined up
some of the best rule breaking moments
in all of Disney Princess history keep
watching to find out which princess is
the biggest rule breaker of all time
wake up looking perfect Disney
Princesses must always look their best
even if they just woke up right well not
according to Princess Anna from frozen
when she woke up for coronation day she
looked like a bunch of mice had a party
in her hair all night and did you guys
see that drool dripping down her cheek
princesses don't drool do day well if
your name is on it you totally do do you
guys think she had morning breath too
she's such a rule breaker greet guests
politely when twin Ryder climbed up to
Rapunzel's tower in Disney's Tangled he
was met with a big surprise this is an
obvious example of departing from royal
princess etiquette we're pretty sure
Rapunzel missed the training about
greeting guests politely but who can
blame her she had been locked in a tower
for most of her life so she was bound to
lack a few important social skills
always ride in horse-drawn carriages
Cinderella set the tone for all other
diseased princesses when her fairy
godmother turned a pumpkin into a
horse-drawn carriage she even wrote away
with the prince in a carriage at the end
of her film
when princess has turned this royal
expectation on its head princess
vanellope von schweetz traded in the
horse buggy for some sweet wheels in the
slaughter race game she's living proof
that princes beginning in cyber seats
always listen to your parents this is a
solid rule for any young princess but
there's one princess in particular who
disobeyed her parents wishes in a major
way we're talking of course about
mallanna her parents forbade her from
leaving the island but she just had to
try and sail past the reef to save her
people her sense of adventure saved the
day and encouraged everyone on the
island to travel and take risks
disobedience paid off for this Disney
princess always dressed like a lady you
won't find this Disney character in a
fancy dress waiting for a prince to save
her Mulan broke the law when she took
her father's armor impersonated a male
soldier and fought for the Chinese army
against the Huns and it's a good thing
she did too she saved all of China
because she wasn't afraid to do what was
right for her family and her country
besides it's hard to fight in a dress
use the finest table manners Princess
Tiana was quite surprised to find out
that she had a sudden taste for bugs
after she turned into a frog she had a
hard time controlling her wild tongue
which jumped out of her mouth after a
fly let's just say that proper table
manners were last on her list of
priorities when she got tongue-tied with
Frog Prince Naveen
we're pretty sure princesses are
supposed to keep their tongues inside
their mouths while eating princesses are
not nosy a princess should always mind
her own business unless your name is
Belle and you're trapped in the beasts
castle that is Belle's curiosity got the
best of her when she explored the west
wing of the castle even though the be
strictly forbade her to go in there she
just couldn't help herself so you can go
anywhere you
except the West Wing what's in the West
it's for me and that's where she
discovered a whole heap of Secrets the
beast was trying to hide
we applaud her curiosity always be sweet
some may think that Disney Princesses
should be sweet all the time but
Princess Jasmine sure didn't think so
when she had her pet tiger Raja teach an
arrogant male suitor a lesson we're
pretty sure there's a rule about not
letting your pets snack on the underwear
of royal guests but that didn't stop
Jasmine from sending this dude packing
with a giant hole in the back of his
pants Princess Jasmine is as defiant as
they come but she's not the biggest rule
breaker out of the bunch walk with poise
and posture princesses are taught to
stand up straight and glide along the
floor with an elegant walk but how are
you supposed to do that if it's your
first day with your new legs
Ariel turned in her mermaid fin for some
wobbly new legs and she certainly wasn't
graceful at first she was downright
clumsy but she got the hang of it
eventually you must follow tradition
following in your parents footsteps and
practicing centuries old traditions is
something that all Disney Princesses
tend to do but the biggest rule breaker
of all time refused to honor her
family's legacy we're talking about
Princess Merida of course not only did
she refuse to get engaged but she shot
an arrow to win her own hand in marriage
and beat her suitors on top of that she
never acted like the lady her mother
wanted her to be and there's nothing
wrong with that Princess Merida is a
total rebel
so which rule-breaking Disney Princess
is your favorite tell us in the comments
subscribe to the things to be the first
to see our latest princess videos and
give this video a big thumbs up while
you're at it thanks for watching
[Music]